Salut ! Aujourd'hui j'ai rendez-vous avez mon pote Epictoh de la chaîne Epictoh.
Il voulait que je le mentalise, donc c'est ce que je vais faire aujourd'hui.
Ça y est, je suis avec Epictoh et on est parti mec !
Sauf qu'il n'a pas dormi Epictoh.
-Ouais j'ai les yeux qui sont défoncés !
-C'est tellement facile ! Moi je suis sur une espèce de segway... Comment t'appelles ça toi du coup ?
-Un gyropode. "Segway" c'est la marque.
-Lui, il est sur une roue. Moi je ne sais pas faire de la roue. Je vais essayer tout à l'heure je vais être ridicule !
-Tu vas apprendre, tout à l'heure, et c'est ça qui va être drôle, je pense.
-En fait à la base je suis censé le mentaliser et j'ai l'impression qu'il m'a donné rendez-vous ici pour me ridiculiser, ce qui n'a rien à voir !
-A force de parler à ta caméra, tu vas avoir un poteau devant !
-C'est ça ! [rires]
Ça, vous pouvez retrouver ça sur la chaîne "Sculptures chelous".
Il y a 3 abonnés.
Epictoh, c'est celui.... C'est quoi ça ? Attends, attendez, on est face à un truc...!
-Moi je vais faire le tour pour regarder ce que c'est.
-J'espère au moins qu'on capte la TNT avec. C'est un routeur.
-C'est un routeur ouais ! [rires]
-C'étaient les premiers routeurs !
Epictoh, il a une chaîne qu'est dédiée à l'électronique on peut dire ça ?
-Attends, attends. Quoi ?
Ta chaîne c'est une chaîne dédiée à l'électronique ?
-Ouais à des conneries électroniques.
-Ouais des conneries électroniques, oui.
-Tu rentres dans un magasin, tu éteins les télés et ça c'est des conneries électroniques.
-C'est ça ! Ça c'était tellement drôle ! Je crois que c'est ta première vidéo que j'ai vu de toi ça.
-Ouais, c'est bien, je m'en rappelle tu m'avais dit : "Ah je kiffe bien".
-Ouais ouais, mais vraiment. En plus j'aime bien.
Allez voir sa chaîne c'est vraiment cool !
Tu sais quoi on va monter une chaîne secondaire.
-Exactement !
-Dédiée à l'art moderne, à l'art contemporain, aux grosses sculptures les mecs !
Regardez, c'est un signe du Christ cosmique !
Sylvain Duriff c'est
-Sylvain si tu nous vois, dédicace à toi !
-Mais de toute manière on va bien se marrer quand moi je monterai dans les vaisseaux cosmiques de la vierge Marie et que vous allez rester là...
-Tiens, tu vois ça par exemple ?
Ça c'est l'aileron ça.
C'est l'aileron qu'est tombé.
On était garés là, bon... on a eu un petit problème avec Sylvain...
-C'est le circuit de refroidissement, ou un truc dans le genre. [rires]
[rires] -C'est ça !
-Hello !
-Et Fabrice c'est un pote d'Epictoh qui nous a prêté le matos pour faire cette balade en fait.
Cette balade qui n'avait aucun sens dans la vidéo si ce n'est que de le faire, c'était cool !
Merci Fabrice !
On parlait avec Epictoh de ce qu'on pourrait faire. Moi à la base j'avais prévu un petit truc d'influence et puis lui il pensait que j'allais le mentaliser en mode déduction.
Et en fait, en me parlant ici, il m'a reparlé des techniques de mémoire, genre sur les jeux de cartes, il a galéré à la faire.
J'ai dit que t'avais galéré à retenir des jeux de cartes ou des trucs comme ça.
-Ouais j'avais retenu 3 cartes, c'était cool !
[rires]
-C'est-à-dire qu'il a retenu moins de cartes avec la méthode que sans méthode.
Du coup il est en train de me mettre au défi, il est en train de m'écrire 25 mots ou 30 mots je ne sais plus, que je vais devoir mémoriser.
Du coup, on va essayer de le faire ensemble.
Essayez de le faire avec moi comme ça à la fin de la vidéo, je vous expliquerai comment le faire si vous avez pas tout retenu.
Alors en 1, c'est un gyropode.
Dis donc, je ne sais pas où tu as été prendre cette idée...!
-Je pense que tu vas retrouver des trucs là...
-En 2, c'est une table, d'accord.
En 3 c'est un sablier, en 4 c'est un xylophone.
Pourquoi un xylophone mec ?
-Parce que c'est un mot qu'a l'air compliqué donc...
-Après table, en général les mecs ils mettent chaise et tout.
-Oui, mais je me suis dit, je vais faire des trucs bizarres.
- "Sablier", "xylophone", c'est pas des trucs chelous, c'est pas des trucs dont j'ai l'habitude.
Non, il est bizarre...
[rires]
Poum Poum Tcha !!!
Allez c'est bon, c'est bon pour moi !
Je cache.
Et je récupère, je récupère la caméra, j'ai caché la liste.
J'espère que vous vous en avez retenu.
Moi j'ai essayé de retenir tous les mots et les chiffres associés à ces mots.
Et maintenant Epictoh, tu dois me tester !
Tu dis un numéro n'importe lequel et j'essaye de te retrouver le mot.
-Eh si ça marche...!
Le 13 ?
-En 13 c'est facile, en 13 c'est une gyroroue ce qui n'a rien à voir avec un gyropode.
-Le 10 ?
-En 10 c'est la caméra.
- En 16 ?
-En 16, c'est facile, c'est le vaisseau,  le vaisseau cosmique de la vierge Marie !
En 25 ?
-En 25, ce sont les orbes qui vont avec le vaisseau d'ailleurs.
[Epictoh réfléchi] Le 2 ? Non...
-Pourquoi t'as pas voulu faire la table qui était en 2, t'as préféré le 18 avec la chaise ?
-Ouais c'est ça, ça va ensemble.
-Allez on fait l'inverse tu me dis un mot je te retrouve le numéro, si tu veux.
-Le livre.
-Livre ? Ah put*** pas mal j'avais peur de l'oublier celui-là, il est en 9.
-Le troller ?
-Et le troller... alors lui il va me falloir du temps le troller, pour le retrouver...
le troller, le troller, le troller... [cogite]
Ok, ne me le dis pas, je le retrouverai. Tu ne me le dis pas.
On fait un jeu. Tu me dis pair ou impair.
-Pair.
-Croissant ou décroissant ?
-Croissant.
En 2 c'est la table, en 4 c'est le xylophone, en 6 c'est le sable, en 8...
Yeah ! Yeah ! C'est le troller ! [chante]
C'est ça ?
-Oui.
-En 10 c'est la caméra, on l'avait dit. En 12..., en 14 c'est la guitare, en 16 c'est le vaisseau, en 18 c'est la chaise, en 20... Tiens en 20... Je ne sais plus le 20....?
Il va me revenir le 20... C'est un canapé ?!
C'est ça ? Ouais.
En 22 c'est les lunettes, en 24 c'est le crapaud, et du coup je vais te faire les impairs dans l'ordre décroissant...
En 25..., en 23 c'est les étagères, en 21 ce sont des boites, on ne sait pas de quoi, mais ce sont des boites.
En 19 c'est une bouteille, en 17 c'est aimant sans S et c'est important.
Ce qui nous amène au 15. Le 15 c'est le carton, en 11 c'est l'aspirateur, ça nous fait passer au 9...
-Non !
-De quoi ?!
-Oui, non, c'est moi qui me suis trompé ! Je me suis trompé.
-Mais oui, mais bien sûr !
[rires]
Le 9 c'est le livre, on l'avait dit.
Le 7... Tiens on ne la pas dit le 7 ! Voilà, c'est un casque, on ne l'avait pas enocre dit.
Le 5, on ne l'avait pas dit non plus, c'est la télévision.
Ca nous fait passer au 3, qu'on a pas dit non plus, c'est le sablier.
Et en1, avec... le gyropode !
Yeah ! Yeah !
[applaudissements]
-Comment tu fais ?
-Alors, je ne sais pas si vous avez réussi ou pas !
Vous pouvez le refaire en utilisant un procédé mnémotechnique que j'explique dans un des Master Class du samedi, qui s'appelle la table de rappel.
Je vous mets une petite fiche à cet endroit là, comme ça vous pouvez aussi le refaire, et comme ça Epictoh pourra s'entrainer !
-Ouais... Enfin, j'ai déjà essayé sur les cartes et c'est pas mon truc...
-Et ça, ça l'agace.
Merci mon pote !
-De rien.
-On fait des check parce qu'on est jeunes.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, vous pouvez nous le faire savoir en nous laissant un petit...
Pouce en l'air !
Il était calme le "pouce en l'air" d'aujourd'hui.
Vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo, vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaine.
Et rendez-vous demain 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !